I really want to start with this
I laughed because it's so true your your
20 red flags for women and dating what
what made you come up with those 20 red
flags or those personal experiences or
experiences from other men that you
coach a bit of a combination of both I
wanted to include a useful what not to
do guide in the book because in life I
find it's easier you get better results
if you tend to avoid going certain
places you know what I mean doing
certain things hanging out with certain
people then it is being more specific
about what it is that you want to hang
out with and be with and people you want
to be around sort of thing so the red
flag notion
um you know came to me several years ago
I'd done
probably close to a thousand coaching
calls by that time and it's like the
same thing would keep coming up over and
over again I'd keep copious notes at the
end of each consult and be like you know
when I was writing the book it seemed
pretty obvious that if guys avoid uh
women with these 20 characteristic
traits and you're not going to find a
woman probably that doesn't have any of
them they're going to be super rare you
might find you know like a handful that
might have one or or two that are going
to be somewhat forgivable that they're
taking ownership for but the vast
majority of guys that have terrible
relationships with women get divorced
get taken advantage of are betrayed
um you know in any number of those
senses they'll find that there's a stack
of red flags present in that woman that
they probably didn't know about but
overlooked their Spidey senses might
have picked up on it you know what I
mean well and and reading your book and
the 20 red flags I'm sitting there I'm
reading through the through the 20 red
flag chapter and I'm thinking
yeah I fell for that one
fell for that one fell for that one fell
for that one and and Rich I'm telling
you I wish this book was out when I was
20 years old I really do I think I get
that a lot they could have saved a lot
of people a lot of Heartache so I'm
reading the the red flag stuff and I
actually and and I know you said you may
be working on another book down the road
um
couple red flags that I've noticed in
women that weren't necessarily in there
and I know that you can go on and on and
on with like 50 to 100 red flags
absolutely easily influenced women
and and when I say that rich
it's you have gained notoriety doing
what you do I've gained notoriety doing
what I do you have haters I have haters
and when a woman that you're involved
with or seeing says to you oh did you
see what so and so said about you on
social media
is that true
and it's like listen I'm here they're
here I don't care what they say
stay off the pages stay off the crap
okay because all they want to do is
bring me down and you had written in
your in your book too that haters never
come from above they come from below
explain that to folks who may not get
that uh well hate never comes from above
you
um you'll never get hate from somebody
doing better than you because they're
doing better than you they don't like
they're not envy or jealous of you like
Envy is a terrible emotion that's
usually where it comes from and their
strategy is
I see this guy up there he might have
things that I want or doing things that
I want to be uh surrounded you know by
certain men or women you know for
example so I'm just going to say mean
to bring them down because that's
all I got like when they get to the
point where it's just point and sputter
and they just say mean they don't
even know what they're talking about and
99 of the time
um you just have to laugh at it I mean
if you don't have haters you're probably
not that influential you probably aren't
doing something right you probably
aren't standing up for anything at the
end of the day
um if I may I'd like to kind of take a
few steps back because you brought up
the central red flag of women that are
easily influenced by others and I think
that women in general are far more
influenced by others than men are yes
now strong virtuous Alpha stand-up sort
of guys aren't that easily manipulated
which I think is one of the reasons why
Society culture the state is trying to
soften masculinity and bring men down
because you're more controllable but
women inherently I believe are more
susceptible to manipulation to
propaganda you know if you will you know
the group think in women is quite strong
I think it's an evolutionary result of
them being the softer more protected sex
and men being more disposable so
um you could call it a red flag but I
think you're going to find that present
in a lot of women to some degree well it
is I I agree with you 100 but I think it
also depends on what degree
um women who listen to their their
girlfriends right more than they will
value their man's opinion well Susie
said this and Mary said this and I think
I should do this and I think I should do
that and you know Susie's boyfriend or
Susie's husband doesn't do this or
doesn't do that and and I think women
who hang out with other women who are
dating
beaters okay and pussified Men
I think her girlfriends resent the fact
that she is with somebody who stands in
his own frame as well they do and what
she'll find is women will adopt your
frame if if she sees you as her best
option so it might start with Susie says
this or Susie came across that or the
internet said this you know is that true
sort of thing but if you're on your
purpose you're on your grind you're
doing what you're about you have
yourself as your own mental point of
origin uh you know you're out there
putting your little dent in the universe
doing something of significance what men
will often find is when you're that guy
she will adopt your political views she
will adopt your musical taste she will
adopt even your culinary taste she will
adopt uh you know music that you like
women can form you know to the cup women
are more like water than men need to be
the cup because women fill the cup you
know sort of thing I really hope you
guys enjoyed that clip if you want to
watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out